lo que quiero hacer en este vídeo es
establecer un criterio razonablemente
poderoso que nos permita concluir que un
campo vectorial tiene integrales de
línea que son independientes de la
trayectoria que se elija pero claro
antes déjame explicar a qué me refiero
supongamos que queremos tomar la
integral de línea sobre la curva c df
punto de r y que la curva csb más o
menos así voy a dibujar el plano xy
haber ahí va a estar un eje otro eje voy
a etiquetarlos y aquí es x y supongamos
que la trayectoria empieza en este punto
y empieza a recorrer algo y llega a este
punto final ok a esta curva de aquí
vamos a ponerle se va entonces esta
integral la estamos evaluando sobre la
trayectoria ce ok entonces vamos a decir
que es un campo conservativo o bien que
la integral es independiente de la
trayectoria si a ver déjame escribirlo
por aquí si es igual a la integral de
línea de f punto de r sobre cualquier
otra trayectoria que tenga los mismos
extremos a la primera trayectoria le
vamos a llamarse 1 y a la segunda le
vamos a llamarse 2 entonces este campo
es conservativo si empezando en este
mismo punto a ver aunque nos movamos en
otra trayectoria si llegamos también al
mismo punto que la trayectoria original
digamos de dos de todas formas tenemos
el mismo valor de la integral de línea
es decir que lo único que nos importa es
el punto inicial y el punto final no nos
importa qué es lo que pasa en medio de
la trayectoria o sea para determinar el
valor de la integral de línea no nos
importa cómo llegamos de un lugar a otro
sino simplemente de donde salimos y
adónde llegamos va una vez más cuando
pasa esto decimos que es un campo
conservativo o bien que la integral es
independiente de la trayectoria
antes de que te pruebe el criterio que
te comenté al inicio del vídeo vamos a
añadir una herramienta más a nuestro
arsenal puede ser que hayas escuchado o
tal vez no acerca de la regla de la
cadena para varias variables la regla de
la cadena para varias variables debo
advertirte que no la voy a demostrar en
este vídeo pero lo que sí haré en un
rato es intentar convencerle de que dice
algo muy intuitivo lo que dice es que si
tenemos una función de dos variables
digamos fx pero a la vez xy ya están en
función de una tercera variable t osea
efe de x dt coma 7
entonces podemos derivar efe con
respecto a t de la siguiente forma o sea
que de f
aquí es de t es igual a aquí tenemos dos
variables verdad entonces vamos a
ponerle es igual a la parcial de f con
respecto a x delta efe delta x x la
derivada de x con respecto a t ojo la
derivada de x con respecto al test
normal y está porque es sólo de una
variable
entonces nos queda de x / dt esta es
derivada normal y ésta es derivada
parcial porque f es una función de dos
variables pero todavía no acabamos hay
que sumar cuanto cambia f con respecto a
g o sea delta f del talle multiplicado
por la derivada de con respecto a t
entonces por de y entre de t
bueno no voy a demostrar que esta regla
pero déjame explicarte la intuición que
está detrás
conforme tenemos un cambio en t entonces
f cambia lo que nos dice esta regla de
la cadena es que podemos partir este
cambio
una componente en x y en una componente
en g pero no podemos simplemente sumar
esas dos no que además hay que
considerar los cambios con respecto a t
otra forma de pensarlo es que si
cancelamos este delta x con este de
equis y este del talle con este de g
entonces nos va a quedar un cambio de f
con respecto a t del lado de x y nos va
a quedar un cambio de f con respecto a t
en el lado de las cosas va entonces eso
de ahí nos va a dar el cambio total de f
con respecto a t pues está muy informal
mi argumento verdad pero al menos a mí
si me convence esta es una forma muy
intuitiva de pensar esta va a ser la
herramienta déjame ponerle un asterisco
para acordarnos de ella después pero
ahora vamos a pasar a un campo vectorial
efe pero no es esta misma f de hecho
déjame cambiar de color vamos a ponerle
efe de x
ahora supongamos que por casualidad efe
es el gradiente de un campo escalar es
decir que fs el gradiente de un campo
escalar que vamos a llamar pues f
mayúscula va esto de aquí el gradiente
vamos a escribir que quiere decir f
déjame escribir f digamos aquí abajo no
mejor no no quiero usar un nuevo renglón
lo voy a poner por aquí en medio ok
entonces
efe también es una función de xy verdad
y el gradiente de f lo que quiere decir
es que f el campo vectorial fx que es
igual a la derivada parcial de f
mayúscula con respecto a x x el vector
unitario y más la parcial de f con
respecto a y x j el vector unitario
vertical esto de aquí es simplemente la
definición de gradiente esta de aquí
vámonos a la geometría
vamos a suponer que la superficie que
define fcb más o menos así
ok déjame ponerle aquí arriba efe
mayúscula de x
entonces el gradiente tiene un cierto
significado geométrico lo que nos dice
es en qué dirección la función disminuye
más rápidamente déjame mejor dibujar el
plano x para explicar esto un poco mejor
entonces aquí está el eje z por aquí
está el plano x ye entonces para cada
punto el gradiente asigna un vector que
da la dirección en la cual efe decrece
más rápidamente de hecho más bien va a
quedar algo como de este estilo en este
punto va a quedar hacia esta dirección
aquí hacia acá aquí hacia abajo verdad
porque aquí tenemos una cuenca en la
cual descendemos pero bueno no me quiero
meter en muchos detalles con esta
superficie en particular más bien sólo
quería darte un poquito de la
interpretación geométrica del gradiente
pero si aún te quedan dudas puedes ver
los otros vídeos que tengo del tema
regresando a la pregunta original lo que
queremos es un criterio para que una
integral sea independiente por
trayectorias
ah pues fíjate resulta que si esto de
aquí existe es decir si f
es el gradiente de una función escalar
voy a ponerle aquí si f es igual al
gradiente de alguna función escalar
entonces
efe es conservativo esto es justo lo que
queremos que sea conservativo es
precisamente que las integrales de línea
no dependen de qué trayectoria tomemos
sino simplemente del extremo inicial y
del extremo final va vamos a demostrar
que este criterio funciona entonces
vamos a empezar con la suposición de que
f en efecto puede ser escrito como el
gradiente es decir efe minúscula puede
ser escrito como el gradiente de una f
mayúscula ok entonces ahora vamos a
tomar la integral bueno no sabes que
déjame borrar esto y déjame poner
primero la parametrización de la
trayectoria que vamos a recorrer
entonces tenemos una
r dt dada por x de t x y más 7 x j para
a menor o igual que te menor o igual que
b simplemente es una parametrización
común y corriente que nos permite
definir cualquier trayectoria en dos
dimensiones va ahora vamos a suponer que
efe minúscula
efe minúscula de x
es igual a esto es decir la parcial de f
con respecto a x o sea estamos
suponiendo que se cumplen las hipótesis
verdad esto multiplicado por y más la
parcial de f con respecto a y x j va
entonces dado esto dada esta información
lo que queremos hacer es encontrar la
integral de efe minúscula punto de r
sobre la trayectoria c este de aquí
verdad o sea se está dado por esta
parametrización ok entonces esto de aquí
sería igual a pues tenemos que hacer un
producto punto verdad entonces lo
primero que necesitamos es encontrar df
a ver vamos a ponerle por aquí déjame
escribir de r / dt esto de aquí por
definición es igual a de x / dt
por iu
más de aquí me quedo muy grueso el que
de que con respecto a t por j ok esto de
aquí es de rd t si queremos encontrar
cuánto vale de r nada más entonces
podemos multiplicar por dt siendo
prácticos pero no rigurosos y entonces
pues nos queda así de equis entre de t
por dt i + d i entre de t
por dt j
va entonces si tomamos el producto punto
de efe con de r entonces simplemente
tenemos que multiplicar coordenada
coordenada entonces nos va a quedar
igual a ver déjame ponerle igual a la
integral sobre la trayectoria set si por
el momento lo voy a dejar así y ya
después pongo todo en términos de te va
entonces tenemos la integral sobre c de
f punto de r y esto que nos queda a ver
ahí va para ponerle la parcial de f con
respecto a x por esto de acá lo voy a
poner con amarillo de x / dt y este de
te lo voy a poner de un tercer color
color verde
dt más
la parcial de f mayúscula con respecto
ayer x este término de aquí en color
amarillo para entonces primeras
coordenadas x primeras coordenadas y
luego hay que sumarle segundas
coordenadas x segundas coordenadas
entonces nos queda de f
y hay que multiplicar por vámonos al
amarillo
de entre de té y luego por el dt que
también lo voy a poner con verde de te
sale entonces podemos factorizar el dt
déjame escribir la nueva integral aquí
abajo a ver que podemos agrupar por aquí
a ver nos queda igual a la integral de
pues ahora sí vamos a pasarnos a
términos de té entonces le voy a poner
desde aaa hasta ve de aves nos queda la
parcial de f mayúscula con respecto a x
por de x / dt más estos dos te los voy a
factorizar después la parcial de f con
respecto a g
ve y entre de té y todo eso x de te va
entonces nos queda esta expresión que
suena conocida si verdad por esto fue
por lo que hablé de la regla de la
cadena de varias variables mira vámonos
para arriba
fíjate en esta expresión aquí tenemos
exactamente lo mismo solo que lo tenemos
con efe minúscula es más déjame copiar y
pegar esta expresión para que podamos
apreciar mejor que pasa le voy a dar
aquí copiar voy a bajar y lo voy a pegar
por aquí va entonces esto de aquí es lo
que nos dice la regla de la cadena de
varias variables y esto como se compara
con nuestra integral a ver aquí tenemos
una efe minúscula verdad de fdf de x de
x de temas de fp y de 7
pero aquí que tenemos aquí tenemos delta
f con respecto a xd xd temas delta f del
taller por de g entre de t
entonces estas dos son idénticas si
cambiamos efe minúscula por f
mayúscula va entonces sustituyendo esto
de azul nos queda la integral de ave de
haber entonces tenemos que poner f
mayúscula en vez de efe minúscula
entonces vamos a ponerlo en azul vamos a
poner la derivada de f mayúscula con
respecto a t de t simplemente lo
sustituir con la regla de la cadena deja
de poner el dt con otro color a ésta dt
entonces por la regla de la cadena estas
dos integrales son iguales pero ahora
qué pasa con esta integral pues aquí
tenemos la derivada de una función con
respecto a una variable y estamos
integrando con respecto a esa misma
variable como estamos sacando la anti
derivada de una derivada entonces estas
operaciones se cancelan y nos queda
simplemente efe entonces queda
efe vete y déjame hacer una aclaración a
ver la voy a escribir por aquí abajito
teníamos que f mayúscula era una función
de x y de g pero x y ya son funciones de
t entonces nos queda
efe de x
como dt pero también podemos reescribir
esto como f mayúscula dt porque al final
de cuentas pues f es una función que
simplemente depende de t y bueno esta la
metemos a una equis y una y luego nos
quedan ciertas cosas de evaluadas pero
todas estas tres expresiones son
equivalentes entonces la derivada de f
con respecto a t nos queda esta cosita
de aquí pero cuando tomamos su anti
derivada simplemente nos queda
efe dt vamos a evaluar la vamos a
evaluarla desde a hasta b para ver
cuánto nos queda la integral esto de
aquí es igual a y este es el punto clave
es
efe db - efe ah bueno si quieres
pensarlo en esta anotación
podemos escribir lo como efe de x dv
coma lleve a ver si ese reto de los
paréntesis
- efe de x de a como más idea vale estas
dos expresiones de aquí son equivalentes
f mayúscula lo tenemos que evaluar en un
punto del plano xy es decir si tomamos
un cierto punto digamos aquí nos da una
cierta altura y entonces esta expresión
nada más nos está diciendo que se lo
tenemos que evaluar en x de bmw va pero
regresemos a la integral de línea
original déjame copiarla aquí abajo lo
que obtuvimos es igual a la integral de
línea sobre c de f punto de r
entonces recapitulemos efe minúscula es
un campo vectorial estamos suponiendo
que es el gradiente de f mayúscula un
campo escalar es decir f es el gradiente
de f
va esta fue la hipótesis con la que
empezamos a partir de esta hipótesis
hicimos un poquito de álgebra o cálculo
como quieras llamarlo pero finalmente a
lo que llegamos fue a que para
determinar el valor de la integral basta
con evaluar f mayúscula igual a b y a
eso restar f mayúscula evaluar ente
iguala pero esto justo lo que nos dice
es que el valor de esta integral de
línea depende únicamente del punto
inicial para t iguala a o sea este de
aquí es el punto x de a coma idea y del
punto final es decir de este punto de
acá x de v coma gdv piénsalo tantito si
vamos a la integral de acá abajo lo
único que nos está pidiendo es poder
evaluar esta función de aquí en los
puntos extremos en la respuesta final no
nos importa qué trayectoria seguimos ok
recapituló todo con palabras entonces
tenemos que sí
efe es el gradiente de a veces también
se dice que efe minúscula es la función
potencial de f mayúscula
pero es la misma idea efe minúscula es
el gradiente de un campo escalar f
mayúscula entonces podemos concluir que
f
conservativo o bien que la integral de
línea sobre cede
efe punto de r es independiente de la
trayectoria es decir que depende
únicamente de sus puntos extremos
qué resultado tan bonito nos vemos en
los próximos vídeos para ver algunos de
sus ejemplos y sus consecuencias